in an exclusive interview with CBS News  Boeing CEO admits the company has made  some mistakes but he says a new software  update will make the 737 max among the  safest planes ever to fly 346 people as  you know died in those accidents  involving that 737 max airliner newly  announced CBS Evening News anchor that's  Nour O'Donnell we know her asked Denis  Muhlenberg about the people flying those  planes I've heard you suggest that the  pilots could have handled the situation  in the cockpit better but safety experts  have told CBS News  it's not fair to blame the pilots our  purpose is not to point fingers or  assigned fault that's that's not our job  our purpose is to understand what  happened in the accidents so we can make  flying even safer Nora will be here at  the table in our next half-hour with  more of her interview all right looking  forward to that